And he asked the question of like, you know, does C++ have a good way to take an item out of a sequence and put it back somewhere else? That was literally the question. I'm like, I can't believe this has landed in my lap on my screen. I'm like, I can't believe I'm about to say this. That's a rotate. And so it's literally the Euclid's GCD. It's just subtraction is swap ranges. And then you just run Euclid's GCD. It's just subtraction is swap ranges. And then you design Euclid's algorithm, which is very beautiful, right?
他问了一个问题，比如，你知道，C++ 有没有一种好的方法可以把一个元素从序列中取出来，然后放到别的地方去？这真的是他的原话。我说，我简直不敢相信这事儿会落到我头上，出现在我的屏幕上。我说，我简直不敢相信我竟然要说出这个答案。那就是 rotate（旋转）。这实际上就是欧几里得的 GCD（最大公约数）算法。减法就是交换区间，然后你运行欧几里得 GCD 算法。减法就是交换区间。然后你设计出欧几里得算法，这非常美妙，对吧？
It's this beautiful connection between a mathematic notation and this operation. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 202, recorded on September 26, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat with Sean Parent about stood rotate, GCD, elements of programming from mathematics to generic programming and more. All righty. We are, I believe, recording now episode 202. I think I failed to mention it on episode 201, but I'm considering this season two. Season one was a reasonable 200 episodes,
这是数学符号和这种操作之间美妙的联系。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，第 202 期，录制于 2024 年 9 月 26 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起，我们与 Sean Parent 聊了聊 std::rotate、GCD、从数学到泛型编程的编程要素等等。好了，我相信我们现在正在录制第 202 期。我想我在第 201 期时忘了提，但我把这期视为第二季。第一季有 200 期，是一个合理的数字。
and now we've started season two after almost four years. And we're going to be trying some different things. You know, after four years, we gotta, we gotta change things up a bit, but we had episode 199. It was entitled stood rotate. And Bryce and I fumbled our way through trying to talk about how would you implement a rotate and miss the fact that the number of operations on the linear algorithm is basically half the length. Realized that with like five minutes left in the podcast recording. We apologize to Sean, understanding that if he did listen to this, he would be disappointed. I believe you were disappointed, but you accepted our apology on Twitter.
现在我们在近四年后开始了第二季。我们将尝试一些不同的东西。你知道，四年过去了，我们得做出一些改变，但我们有第 199 期。那一期标题是 std::rotate。我和 Bryce 在尝试讨论如何实现 rotate 时笨手笨脚，漏掉了线性算法的操作次数基本上是长度的一半这一事实。在播客录制还剩五分钟时才意识到这一点。我们向 Sean 道歉，因为如果他听了那一期，他会感到失望。我相信你确实失望了，但你在 Twitter 上接受了我们的道歉。
And you were one of three people. So you tweeted Sean saying that at least you apologized. In STL, there are three algorithms used for rotate, Fletcher and Silver for random access, three reverses for bidirectional, the one we discussed, and then Grease and Mills for forward iterators. And you mentioned that Grease and Mills is Euclid's subtractive GCD algorithm. Ben DM'd me and mentioned the same thing I believe about the forward iterator algorithm. And then Tristan also tweeted and I think linked to a paper talking about the forward
而且你是那三个人之一。所以你在推特上对 Sean 说，至少你们道歉了。在 STL 中，有三种用于 rotate 的算法：Fletcher 和 Silver 用于随机访问迭代器，三次 reverse 用于双向迭代器（我们讨论的那种），然后是 Gries 和 Mills 用于前向迭代器。你提到 Gries 和 Mills 的算法就是欧几里得的减法 GCD 算法。Ben 私信我，提到了关于前向迭代器算法的同样的事情，我相信。然后 Tristan 也发了推文，我想他还链接了一篇关于前向
iterator version. So now we've brought on two of the three people that messaged me. Tristan, don't worry. We have, I think, lined up. We're going to bring him back on to talk about the sort of changes and recent updates to Flux. We were actually supposed to record when I was in London back in August, but we ended up meeting up at his local pub in, oh my goodness, I'm going to forget the name of the town that is just on the outside of London. But we met up twice, actually. And I got to see, we actually went on a bird walk. If you can guess at it, I might be able to recognize it. If you've got like. Oh, it's, it's, Iick rickman's rickman's worth i believe yeah that's it that'll be it which is yeah not in london but adjacent to london it's slightly up the a40 i'm gonna say something like that the m40 it's south it's uh a North Northwest. Yes. I subwayed and we can actually blame Taylor Swift for the reason that we didn't record
迭代器版本的论文。所以现在我们请来了给我发消息的三个人中的两个。Tristan，别担心。我想我们已经安排好了。我们会请他回来聊聊 Flux 的一些变化和最近的更新。其实我们本应在我八月份在伦敦时录制的，但我们最终在他当地的酒吧见面了，哦天哪，我要忘了那个就在伦敦郊外的小镇的名字了。但我们实际上见了两次面。我看到了，我们还去观鸟了。如果你能猜到，我或许能认出来。如果你有……哦，是 Rickmansworth，我想。是的，就是那个，那肯定就是了，它不在伦敦，但紧邻伦敦，在 A40 公路稍微往上一点，我想是 M40 公路，它在南边，呃，西北方向。是的。我坐了地铁，我们其实可以把没能录制的原因归咎于 Taylor Swift。
because she was performing at Wembley stadium and I ended up getting out there like an hour later because of all the Swift fans that were taking the underground. And so we'll blame Taylor Swift. And I apologize to any listeners that are big fans uh but it is the case that her concert and her fans delayed me getting out there anyways i'm gonna throw it over to to you two now i'm not sure if sean you want to start first um because i did not go ahead and do any research on these other uh implementations i figured i would just learn via inviting you on and, uh, yeah,
因为她在温布利球场演出，我因为所有乘坐地铁的 Swift 粉丝，最终晚了一个小时才到那里。所以我们要怪 Taylor Swift。我向任何是她忠实粉丝的听众道歉，但事实是她的演唱会和她的粉丝确实耽误了我赶过去。无论如何，我现在要把话语权交给你们两位了，我不确定 Sean 你是否想先开始，嗯，因为我没有去对这些其他的实现做任何研究，我想我还是通过邀请你来做客来学习，嗯，是的。
let me get maybe your thoughts while you were listening to it. How upset were you? And, uh, once, once again, Bryce and I both apologize. Uh, yeah, well, it was annoying because I think both of you guys probably have elements of programming and all of these algorithms are covered in, in EOP. Uh, uh, so you could have just like cracked the book and taken a look. The other piece of it is anytime you're dealing with a permutation algorithm, every permutation algorithm decomposes into a set of cycles. And what that means is if you think about, I can remove one element, and then if I know what piece goes into that element, I move that piece into the hole and that leaves another hole. And so something moves into that hole and it keeps going until the
让我听听你在听那一期时的想法吧。你有多生气？而且，再一次，我和 Bryce 都道歉。嗯，好吧，这很烦人，因为我觉得你们俩可能都有《编程要素》（Elements of Programming）这本书，而所有这些算法在 EOP 中都有涵盖。所以你们本可以翻翻书看一眼的。另一部分是，每当你处理置换算法时，每个置换算法都会分解成一组循环。这意味着如果你考虑一下，我可以移除一个元素，然后如果我知道什么碎片应该进入那个元素的位置，我就把那个碎片移进那个空洞，这又留下了另一个空洞。所以有东西移进那个空洞，它会一直持续，直到
one element that I took out goes into the hole. And so that creates a cycle going around. And so kind of the worst case is if you're doing a reverse for the number of cycles, because you're going to have every swap is a trivial cycle of two elements, right? It turns out that when you're doing a rotate, that the number of cycles you have is the GCD of the length of the two halves right so so that's how the cycles decompose that's why you have the complexity of the random axis algorithm that's why the complexity of that is driven by gcd and so you know your worst case then is where the ranges are are equal length and which case rotate is just a swap ranges and every cycle is just a swap but that algorithm if you're given random access minimizes the number
我取出的那个元素进入了空洞。所以这就形成了一个循环。所以最坏的情况是如果你在做 reverse（反转）的循环次数，因为你会有每一次交换都是两个元素的平凡循环，对吧？事实证明，当你做 rotate 时，你拥有的循环次数是两半长度的 GCD。所以这就是循环分解的方式，这就是为什么你有随机访问算法的复杂度，这就是为什么它的复杂度是由 GCD 驱动的。所以你知道，你的最坏情况是区间长度相等，在这种情况下，rotate 只是一个 swap_ranges（交换区间），每个循环只是一个交换。但如果你有随机访问权限，那个算法会最小化
of moves it goes through each cycle and so every element is is only is only moved into its final position so you're going to have if you have n elements you're going to have, if you have n elements, you're going to have n moves plus one for each cycle. So it's going to be n moves plus GCD of nm moves. So that's how you can do that. Now, the interesting thing is the complexity of the forward iterator case and the complexity of the three reverses case is the same number of moves. Just clarification there, Sean. Do you mean that they're the same number of moves as each other or as the random access case? As each other.
移动次数，它会遍历每个循环，所以每个元素只会被移动到它的最终位置。所以如果你有 n 个元素，你会有 n 次移动，每个循环加一次。所以它将是 n 次移动加上 GCD(n, m) 次移动。这就是你可以做到的方式。现在，有趣的是，前向迭代器情况的复杂度和三次反转情况的复杂度是相同的移动次数。Sean，澄清一下。你是说它们彼此之间的移动次数相同，还是和随机访问情况相同？彼此之间。
Okay. Which is going to be more because you're you're breaking it down all into all into swaps and so if you're doing three reverses right then then you're going to to uh you're going to reverse each half or each each segment and then reverse the whole and and so each of those uh reverses is n over swaps. And so you're going to have n over 2 plus n plus m swaps. When you're doing it with forward iterators, you're swapping elements. How to describe this? So you're basically going to swap ranges when the two are equal, are
好的。这会更多，因为你把一切都分解成了交换，所以如果你在做三次反转，那么你将反转每一半或每个段，然后反转整个序列，所以那些反转中的每一个都是 n/2 次交换。所以你会有 n/2 + n + m 次交换。当你用前向迭代器做这件事时，你在交换元素。怎么描述这个呢？所以你基本上是在两个区间相等时交换区间，是
unequal halves. And so you're going to be swapping ranges up until you hit the midpoint. And then that leaves you a new piece. And then you're going to swap that piece and then swap that piece. Okay. And so you're going to end up swapping every element, calling swap for
不相等的两半。所以你会一直交换区间直到到达中点。然后这会给你留下一个新的碎片。然后你会交换那个碎片，然后再交换那个碎片。好的。所以你最终会交换每个元素，对每个元素调用一次 swap。所以这和三次旋转是一样的。
every element once. And so that's the same as the three rotates. Now, I suspect, but I haven't tested it, that the forward algorithm these days probably wins. I don't know that we could make the change in STL because we have the guarantees on number of moves for the random access case. But just because of locality and caches, it's much faster to iterate through a sequence always going forward. Always moving forward. And so almost positive that that always wins over three reverses, which is the bidirectional iterator case. And I would be very surprised if you have a low-cost move if it didn't win even over the random access case, which would have fewer move operations but horrible locality because you're you're tracing cycles all all through your sequence um so even worse locality than the than the random access case for something like thrust
现在，我怀疑，但我还没有测试过，前向算法在今天可能胜出。我不知道我们是否能在 STL 中做出改变，因为我们对随机访问情况下的移动次数有保证。但仅仅因为局部性和缓存，遍历序列总是向前移动要快得多。总是向前移动。所以我几乎肯定它总是胜过三次反转，也就是双向迭代器的情况。如果你的移动成本很低，我会非常惊讶它甚至没有胜过随机访问情况，后者虽然移动操作较少，但局部性很差，因为你会在整个序列中追踪循环，所以对于像 Thrust 这样的东西，它的局部性甚至比随机访问情况还要差。
which apparently is missing rotate which is a crime how is it possible to miss rotate it's a fundamental building block right if you're missing, how are you implementing a bunch of stuff which depends on rotate? In defense of the good folks at NVIDIA, David Olson, who we interviewed on that CPP North episode for the first 10 or 12 minutes, he pinged me after the episode went live and said, this is on a GitHub issue
Thrust 显然缺少 rotate，这简直是犯罪。怎么可能漏掉 rotate？它是一个基本的构建块，对吧？如果你缺少它，你是怎么实现一堆依赖于 rotate 的东西的？为 NVIDIA 的好伙伴们辩护一下，David Olson，我们在那期 CPP North 采访的前 10 或 12 分钟里采访过他，他在那期节目上线后 ping 了我，说这在一个 GitHub issue 上
that was filed in like 2012 or something like that when in the early days and then they pointed out that these algorithms are missing and we should add them and it's actually because of that because the stdpar mvc++ compiler that implements you know you'd write c++ and can easily parallelize it by just passing a flag. There's a couple algorithms that actually aren't supported and rotate is one of them because thrust is what it lowers down onto. But anyways, we we'll, we're getting to it, Bryce and I, we're going to fix it. Or by we, I mean, probably, you know, David and friends, but you know, in it by episode 400, this is an ADSP promise, you know, another four years from now, there'll definitely be a thrust rotate.
在 2012 年左右或者类似的时间被提交过，当时在早期阶段，然后他们指出这些算法缺失了，我们应该添加它们。实际上是因为这个原因，因为 stdpar nvc++ 编译器实现了，你知道，你会写 C++，并且可以通过传递一个标志轻松地并行化它。有几个算法实际上是不支持的，rotate 就是其中之一，因为 Thrust 是它所降级到的底层。但无论如何，我们会解决它的，我和 Bryce，我们会修复它。或者说“我们”，我的意思是，可能是 David 和他的朋友们，但你知道，到第 400 期，这是一个 ADSP 的承诺，你知道，再过四年，肯定会有 Thrust rotate。
So rotate, I was going to say rotate is one of these algorithms that really has a kind of, people experience a semantic gap. In general, because in C++ the algorithms are called what they do at a very low level rather than what they do at a domain level. So partial sort is not called top end, for example. And rotate is one of these others that people see the explanation of what it does and they go away and they think, well, I don't ever do that in my code. And getting to the realization that yes, we actually do that all the time is one of the reasons why, you know, C++ seasoning was such a eyeopening moment for many folks.
所以 rotate，我想说 rotate 是这些算法之一，人们确实有一种语义鸿沟。通常是因为在 C++ 中，算法的命名是基于它们在极低层面上所做的事情，而不是它们在领域层面上所做的事情。例如，partial_sort 不叫 top_n。而 rotate 是人们看到它的解释后走开，心想“我从来不在代码里做那个”的算法之一。意识到“是的，我们确实一直在做那个”，是“C++ Seasoning”对许多人来说是一个大开眼界时刻的原因之一。
And Connor, your talks about algorithm intuition similarly. The funniest thing that ever happened to me on twitter was where one of my friends it was uh alan wolf who's on graphics twitter and and uh he was we he and i used to work together and he asked the question of like you know does c-plus have a good way to uh to take an item out of a sequence and put it back somewhere else that was literally the question i'm like i can't believe this has landed in my lap on my screen of a sequence and put it back somewhere else? That was literally the question. I'm like, I can't believe this has landed in my lap on my screen.
Connor，你关于算法直觉的演讲也类似。我在 Twitter 上遇到的最有趣的事情是，我的一个朋友，Alan Wolf，他在图形学推特圈，我们曾经一起工作过，他问了一个问题，比如，你知道，C++ 有没有一种好的方法可以把一个元素从序列中取出来，然后放到别的地方去？这真的是他的原话。我说，我简直不敢相信这事儿会落到我头上，出现在我的屏幕上。
I'm like, I can't believe I'm about to say this. That's a rotate. Yeah, that's right. You just answer that one with the link to Connor's cut of my seasoning talk. Which the seasoning talk is 10 years old now, so I can't believe we're still talking about it. Yeah, but it is a fundamental rotate.
我说，我简直不敢相信我竟然要说出这个答案。那就是 rotate。是的，没错。你只需要用 Connor 剪辑的我的 Seasoning 演讲的链接来回答那个问题。那个 Seasoning 演讲现在已经 10 年了，所以我简直不敢相信我们还在谈论它。是的，但它是一个基本的 rotate。
And if you look at, you know, Connor's an array programming guy, and a rotate, you know, has its own operator in APL. And it is a very fundamental algorithm and building block. So it definitely deserves to be in thrust. You know, the interesting thing is like the three reverses is probably the most trivially parallelizable because reverse itself, all of your cycles are independent. So you can run all of those.
如果你看看，你知道，Connor 是个数组编程专家，而 rotate 在 APL 中有它自己的运算符。它确实是一个非常基本的算法和构建块。所以它绝对值得被加入 Thrust。你知道，有趣的是，三次反转可能是最容易并行化的，因为反转本身，你所有的循环都是独立的。所以你可以运行所有这些。
You can chunk up those cycles however you want and run them all independently. I think the forward iterator case to run in parallel would require a little more thought, but again, it decomposes all into swaps. So I think you could break it up pretty well. I've never attempted it, but I think doing a fast parallel rotate is interesting. Is that true about the three reverse implementation? Because you do the two n over two or wherever your midpoint is.
你可以随心所欲地切分这些循环，并让它们全部独立运行。我认为前向迭代器的情况要并行运行需要多一点思考，但同样，它全部分解为交换。所以我认为你可以很好地拆分它。我从未尝试过，但我认为做一个快速的并行 rotate 很有趣。关于三次反转的实现，那是真的吗？因为你做了两个 n/2 或者无论你的中点在哪里。
You do those two reverses. But then the final reverse on the whole sequence, isn't that dependent on the previous two? Well, yeah. final reverse on the whole sequence isn't that dependent on the previous two well yeah but it's not that you do like the first two well you do do the first two reverses you do them in parallel but it's not the fact that you can do a re that you can do those two reverses simultaneously it's that an individual reverse individual has no there's no dependency between each cycle. You can break that and do it on a thousand cores. It stays a parallel.
你做了那两次反转。但随后对整个序列的最后一次反转，难道不依赖于前两次吗？嗯，是的。但并不是说你做像前两次那样，嗯，你确实做了前两次反转，你并行地做它们，但并不是说你可以同时做那两次反转，而是单个反转没有任何依赖关系，每个循环之间没有依赖。你可以打破它并在 1000 个核心上运行。它保持并行。
Right. It doesn't suffer from the communication issue that scanned, or suffers the wrong word, but it doesn't have that property of a scan that you're constantly needing to refer back and figure out a way to propagate that information. Reverse doesn't have that. Every swap is data parallel with every other swap.
对。它不会遭受 scan 那样的通信问题，或者“遭受”这个词用错了，但它没有 scan 那种你需要不断回溯并找出传播该信息的方法的特性。Reverse 没有那个。每一次交换都与每一次其他交换是数据并行的。
Right. Right. The random access algorithm, minimizing the number of moves in parallel gets more challenging because you need to identify the start points of all of your cycles. And then in theory, you could run each of those cycles in parallel. But again, I'm not sure if the memory access patterns would kill the gains you'd get off of that. The other thing is, in some cases, you're going to run into the case where the number of cycles is one. And so, in which case, you can't parallelize it. You've got to run through the whole thing.
对。对。随机访问算法，在并行中最小化移动次数变得更具挑战性，因为你需要识别所有循环的起点。然后理论上，你可以并行运行每一个循环。但同样，我不确定内存访问模式是否会抵消你从中获得的收益。另一件事是，在某些情况下，你会遇到循环次数为 1 的情况。在这种情况下，你无法并行化它。你必须遍历整个过程。
At least I don't know of a way to parallelize that so it's interesting again my intuition says that the forward algorithm probably probably wins in the parallel case probably wins in all cases uh but that's without you know you have to implement them all in benchmark it right i, machines these days are nuts for breaking intuition. So I had a similar experience when I was listening to the episode. I was listening and I thought, OK, well, they're explaining the hand flipping algorithm. Any minute now, they're going to explain how the forward iterator algorithm is basically GCD algorithm. And they're going to explain how that works. And then I noticed that it was at like 28 minutes of 30 in the episode, and I'm like, maybe they're not going to get to it.
至少我不知道有什么方法可以并行化它，所以这很有趣。同样，我的直觉告诉我，前向算法在并行情况下可能胜出，可能在所有情况下都胜出，但那是在你没有实现它们并进行基准测试的情况下。现在的机器在打破直觉方面简直疯了。所以我听那一期时也有类似的经历。我听着，心想，好吧，他们正在解释手工翻转算法。他们随时都会解释前向迭代器算法基本上就是 GCD 算法。他们会解释它是如何工作的。然后我注意到那是那一期的 30 分钟里的第 28 分钟，我想，也许他们不会讲到那儿了。
Right. For the listener, if you're having trouble viewing why rotate is GCD, well, first, GCD is greatest common divisor, and Euclid's algorithm for greatest common divisor is you subtract the smaller number from the bigger number. If the result is now smaller, then you flip the two and you just keep going. So it's just iterative subtraction, right, until the parts are equal size, and then you stop. And so if you think of swap ranges as your subtraction operation, then you can say, okay, I've got two unequal
对。对于听众来说，如果你很难理解为什么 rotate 是 GCD，好吧，首先，GCD 是最大公约数，欧几里得的最大公约数算法是你从较大的数字中减去较小的数字。如果结果现在变小了，那么你就翻转这两个数字，然后继续。所以它只是迭代减法，对吧，直到各部分大小相等，然后你就停止。所以如果你把 swap_ranges 看作你的减法操作，那么你可以说，好的，我有两个大小不等的
size sequences and I can swap ranges which will stop when I hit the end of the shorter segment. And so that's subtracting the shorter segment from the shorter segment. And so that's subtracting the shorter segment from the longer segment. Okay. And so now what I end up with after I do that is I'm done with the beginning up to the point where I stopped. And now I have a piece left of which I stopped somewhere halfway through there. And so that gives me my three points, my three numbers to
序列，我可以交换区间，这会在我到达较短段的末尾时停止。所以这就是从较短的段中减去较短的段。所以这就是从较长的段中减去较短的段。好的。所以现在我做完这些后得到的结果是，我完成了从开始到我停止的地方。现在我剩下了一块，我在那块的中间某处停止了。所以这给了我三个点，我的三个数字来
continue my subtraction. And so it's literally the Euclid's GCD, it's just subtraction is swap ranges. And then you just run Euclid's algorithm. Which is very beautiful, right? It's this beautiful connection between a mathematic notation and this and this operation and that's why yeah gcd keeps popping out right right right the number of cycles is gcd number of cycles and and and so so the complexity of the random axis algorithm it gets described in gcd because there's there's no more minimal way to do it
继续我的减法。所以它真的是欧几里得 GCD，只是减法变成了交换区间。然后你只需运行欧几里得算法。这非常美妙，对吧？这是数学符号和这种操作之间美妙的联系，这就是为什么 GCD 不断出现，对吧，对吧，对吧。循环次数就是 GCD，循环次数，所以随机访问算法的复杂度是用 GCD 描述的，因为没有更最小化的方法来做它了。
yeah so i always think of algorithms recursively i think that's at least the right way to think about algorithms you know when you code them you can remove the recursion but to me the right way to think about algorithms is recursively and that's exactly what you just said short like like what do you do with rotate well you put you put the things at the beginning of the range first right you rotate something into the beginning of the range and then it stops at some point then what are you left with and you rotate effectively that is smaller than the old one and so recursively that that works and that is gcd as you said right so this is i don't know i feel bad admitting this on air especially after having had zach on because i think actually there's
是的，所以我总是递归地思考算法，我认为这至少是思考算法的正确方式。你知道，当你编写它们时，你可以移除递归，但对我来说，思考算法的正确方式是递归的，这正是你刚才说的，Sean。比如，你对 rotate 做什么？好吧，你先把区间开头的东西放好，对吧？你把某样东西旋转到区间的开头，然后它在某一点停止，然后你剩下什么？你旋转的实际上比旧的那个小，所以递归地，这行得通，这就是 GCD，正如你所说，对吧？所以我不知道，我为在节目中承认这一点感到难过，特别是在请过 Zach 之后，因为我认为实际上还有
another thing to point out we have our two most frequent guests so you guys are just putting uh you know more distance on the rest of our guests but uh we had zach on i think he's up there for a number of episodes um and he said the way to do it is to read eop elements of programming available free online link in the show notes three times you you you know you don't skim through it but you read through it quickly without stopping to digest everything and that doesn't take too long then you go through a second time and that's the one where you treat it like a textbook you know work through things try to understand them and then you read it a third and final time at the same speed you read it the first time I have not
另一件事要指出，我们有我们最频繁的两位嘉宾，所以你们正在和我们的其他嘉宾拉开距离。但我们请了 Zach，我想他在期数上名列前茅，他说做这件事的方法是阅读《编程要素》（EOP），网上免费提供，链接在节目说明中，读三遍。你不是略读它，而是快速读一遍，不停下来消化所有东西，那不需要太久。然后你读第二遍，那是你把它当作教科书对待的时候，你知道，钻研这些东西，试着理解它们，然后你以第一遍相同的速度读第三遍，也是最后一遍。我还没有
actually fully read EOP. I'm not sure if, you know, Sean's heart is breaking right now, but there's two things that have been high on my list of things to do. I know both of you have done them. Obviously, Sean's read EOP and so has Ben, but also too, Ben, you have watched the,
完全读完 EOP。我不确定 Sean 的心现在是否在滴血，但有两件事一直是我待办事项清单上的重中之重。我知道你们俩都做过。显然，Sean 读过 EOP，Ben 也读过，但还有，Ben，你还看了
what is it? It's the four algorithmic journeys that came out of A9. Is that the correct title of the? what is it it's the four algorithmic journeys that was that came out of a9 is that that is that the correct title of the uh i think yes it's algorithmic journeys um yeah there's a hundred hours plus of a9 video content presentations from alex stepanov within amazon a9 they are i would highly recommend them to everyone. Those Algorithmic Journeys videos are the video version, if you like, of the second book, which is From Mathematics to Generic Programming. And that book in particular explores GCD a lot. Yes. GCD comes up repeatedly in it. And Sean, I know that you gave, if not attended, some of those.
那个是什么？是来自 A9 的四个算法之旅。那是正确的标题吗？我想是的，是“算法之旅”。是的，有超过一百小时的 A9 视频内容，是 Alex Stepanov 在 Amazon A9 内部的演讲，我强烈推荐给所有人。那些“算法之旅”视频如果你喜欢的话，是第二本书《从数学到泛型编程》的视频版本。那本书特别深入地探讨了 GCD。是的。GCD 在其中反复出现。Sean，我知道你即使没参加，也看过其中一些。
I definitely know you were a guest speaker, I think, as one of those talks. That is Programming Conversations, Lecture 5, Part 2. I'm not sure if it's Part 1 or 2, maybe both. It's the one that you give the extended version of the Google Rotate story, I believe, in that edition, which I think we've talked about on this podcast. But I've never said that I actually haven't watched all of them, even though for years now I've had it linked as a bookmark. But the problem is, is that my curiosity is too vast that I. So I've seen little pieces. I've definitely seen the 2002, is it, Stepanov talk that I've cited in a couple, which I think he came and
我绝对知道你是嘉宾演讲者，我想是其中之一。那是《编程对话》第 5 讲，第 2 部分。我不确定是第 1 部分还是第 2 部分，也许两者都是。那是你给出 Google Rotate 故事扩展版本的那一讲，我相信，我们在本播客中讨论过。但我从未说过我实际上没有看完所有这些，尽管多年来我一直把它作为书签链接。但问题是，我的好奇心太强了，所以我看过一点点。我绝对看过 2002 年的 Stepanov 演讲，我在几期节目中引用过，我想他来过
gave at Adobe. How many of those did you see that were given at A9 slash, I assume you just know most of that stuff, probably from conversations directly with Alex. Well, yeah, so I don't know, I attended a few of them. I watched, I think all of them online, you know, plus Alex and I worked largely in the same room together for eight years. So I'm I'm I'm pretty familiar with most of most of his material there. I did link in the show notes to Alex's talk on or I linked to it on Twitter, which that will be in the show notes, to my favorite talk of all time, which is Alex's GCD talk. It's the history of GCD, the last 2,500 years. And that's one of the journeys from mathematics to generic programming, which I love that title. And Alex views it as generic programming is the next step in mathematics, is the arc there.
Adobe 演讲。你看了多少个在 A9 演讲的？我假设你大部分都知道，可能是直接与 Alex 对话得知的。嗯，是的，所以我不知道，我参加了其中几个。我在网上看了我想是所有的，你知道，加上 Alex 和我在同一个房间里一起工作了八年。所以我对他的大部分材料都很熟悉。我在节目说明中链接了 Alex 关于 GCD 的演讲，或者我在 Twitter 上链接了它，那会在节目说明中，那是我有史以来最喜欢的演讲，就是 Alex 的 GCD 演讲。那是过去 2500 年 GCD 的历史。那是从数学到泛型编程的旅程之一，我喜欢那个标题。Alex 认为泛型编程是数学的下一步，这是其中的主线。
That mathematicians have been working on algorithms and how you solve problems for centuries and kind of moving that into the computer domain as part of it. And mathematics we think of as being relatively abstract, and generic programming is carrying those mathematical abstractions into the programming space. You know, that book in particular for the listener and for you, Connor, pick up a copy, read it. That's, compared to EOP, it's a much easier read. It's not a textbook. It's stories. And so it's a lot of history. It's a little bit of math, and a little bit of programming, and they're stories. They're tracing the origin of fundamental algorithms through history,
数学家们几个世纪以来一直致力于算法和如何解决问题，并将其引入计算机领域作为其中的一部分。我们认为数学相对抽象，而泛型编程是将这些数学抽象带入编程空间。你知道，那本书特别适合听众和你，Connor，买一本，读一读。与 EOP 相比，它读起来容易得多。它不是教科书。它是故事。所以它有很多历史。它有一点数学，一点编程，它们是故事。它们追溯了基本算法在历史上的起源，
and looking at the mathematicians who extended or improved on the algorithm through history, and what their motivation was, why they were dealing with that particular algorithm at that particular time in history, and what their realization was, and then what the ongoing ramifications of that are. So it's interesting. And even things like GCD, there are still open problems open problems in mathematics well and i'm blanking on the name now but there was the the israeli researcher in the late 60s or early 70s who developed a version of gcd through necessity which i'm blanking on his name yeah uh joseph stein
并观察了历史上扩展或改进该算法的数学家，他们的动机是什么，为什么他们在历史上的那个特定时间处理那个特定的算法，他们的发现是什么，以及随之而来的持续影响是什么。所以这很有趣。即使像 GCD 这样的东西，数学中仍然有未解决的问题。嗯，我忘了名字了，但 60 年代末或 70 年代初有一位以色列研究人员，他出于必要开发了一个版本的 GCD，我忘了他的名字了。是的，Joseph Stein。
stein yes the stein gcd so it's the stein algorithm for GCD, and it's a binary GCD. So it's what you, you know, if you call a GCD on your computer, it's probably what's executing on your computer. The interesting thing is the Euclidean algorithm defines what's known as the Euclidean domain, which is for any kind of abstract number system, if GCD works, if the GCD algorithm terminates this incremental subtraction, if you always end up at zero, basically, by doing incremental subtraction, then that numeric system is in the Euclidean domain. And so the interesting thing is that Stein's algorithm does not appear to be, the numbers for which the Stein algorithm works don't appear to be exactly the same set of numbers for which the Euclidean algorithm works. And so the open question is,
Stein，是的，Stein GCD。所以它是 GCD 的 Stein 算法，它是二进制 GCD。所以如果你在电脑上调用 GCD，这很可能就是你电脑上执行的内容。有趣的是，欧几里得算法定义了所谓的欧几里得域，对于任何类型的抽象数字系统，如果 GCD 有效，如果 GCD 算法终止这种增量减法，如果你总是通过增量减法基本上最终得到零，那么该数字系统就在欧几里得域内。所以有趣的是，Stein 算法似乎并不是，Stein 算法适用的数字似乎并不完全是欧几里得算法适用的数字集合。所以悬而未决的问题是，
is the Stein domain the same as the Euclidean domain? Is it a superset of the Euclidean domain? Is it a subset of the Euclidean domain? And I haven't tracked it closely. I think, you know, last time I looked, there was one proof of something that was in the Stein domain that wasn't Euclidean and one proof of the opposite. So there's this section that there there's some some ven overlap uh but they both
Stein 域和欧几里得域是一样的吗？它是欧几里得域的超集吗？它是欧几里得域的子集吗？我没有密切跟踪它。我想，上次我看的时候，有一个证明说某样东西在 Stein 域中但不是欧几里得的，还有一个相反的证明。所以有这个部分，它们有一些维恩图重叠，但它们都
have have have unique bounds but over time there's been a number of proofs that have just failed right right they people have submitted proofs on that and then then under peer review, the proofs collapse. So as far as I know, it's still an open problem. But, you know, it's pretty amazing. And because of Alex bringing all of this up, and Alex actually managed to contact Joseph Stein, who at least as of a decade ago was was still alive and he was just like a you know engineer working in israel who came up with this algorithm and it got published and went everywhere and he was completely unaware that that there was this whole branch of mathematics research that he triggered. So, wow. When, when you, when, when you say that the, you know, subset or superset of things that it works for, I imagine this doesn't impact like the correctness of what's happening on
有独特的边界，但随着时间的推移，已经有许多证明失败了，对吧？人们提交了关于那个的证明，然后在同行评审下，证明崩溃了。所以据我所知，这仍然是一个悬而未决的问题。但是，这很神奇。而且因为 Alex 提出了所有这些，Alex 实际上设法联系了 Joseph Stein，他至少在十年前还活着，他只是一个在以色列工作的工程师，他想出了这个算法，它被发表并传遍了各地，他完全不知道他触发了整个数学研究分支。所以，哇。当你，当你，当你提到它适用的子集或超集时，我想这不会影响你硬件上发生的事情的正确性。
your hardware. If, if that's the algorithm that's taking, is it the things for like for certain types that it doesn't work or like, what is, what are the edge cases? So, so it's, you know, if you think about number systems like integers, OK, both algorithms work fine for integers. Both algorithms work fine for reals. And then you have things like polynomials with real coefficients or or just complex numbers or. Right. Or. OK, so. So that's what I mean by different types of numbers, right?
如果那是正在执行的算法，是对于某些类型它不起作用，还是说，边缘情况是什么？所以，如果你考虑像整数这样的数字系统，好的，两种算法对整数都适用。两种算法对实数都适用。然后你有像带有实系数的多项式，或者复数，或者。好的。所以，这就是我所说的不同类型的数字，对吧？
Right. Right, and there's an infinite number of ways that you can create new domains for numbers, right? There are sets of them that are useful, but you can make up your own set of rules, and that becomes a number. So if you're dealing much in the abstract algebra space, that's what you're trying to do. And the Euclidean domain is odd in that there's no better definition than the set of numbers for which the Euclid algorithm terminates. Okay? Okay. You can have algorithms that uphold the other axioms of Euclid's algorithm, but there's no axiom better than just the algorithm must terminate. Right. So it's kind of an extrinsic definition. There's nothing intrinsic to say. It's just kind of like the fifth postulate, you know, it is because it is.
对，对，你可以创造新的数字域的方法有无数种，对吧？有一组是有用的，但你可以制定你自己的规则集，那就会变成一个数字。所以如果你在抽象代数空间中处理很多问题，那就是你试图做的。欧几里得域很奇怪，因为没有比“欧几里得算法终止的数字集合”更好的定义了。好的？好的。你可以有支持欧几里得算法其他公理的算法，但没有比“算法必须终止”更好的公理了。所以它是一种外在的定义。没有什么内在的东西可以说。它有点像第五公理，你知道，它之所以是这样，是因为它就是这样。
Right. And that makes it very difficult. There's no single axiom that you can point to and say, oh, so long as my number system satisfies X, then it's within the Euclidean domain. Because the definition of it within the Euclidean domain is so long as Euclid's algorithm terminates. And that gets to be very interesting to try to prove or disprove for any two numbers within a given domain, does Euclid's algorithm terminate or not? And that's an open question. There's no general rule to it. There are many proofs for many different domain instances. Yes. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com
对。这使得证明非常困难。没有单一的公理可以指出并说，哦，只要我的数字系统满足 X，那么它就在欧几里得域内。因为欧几里得域内的定义是只要欧几里得算法终止。对于给定域内的任意两个数字，试图证明或反驳欧几里得算法是否终止，这变得非常有趣。这是一个悬而未决的问题。没有通用的规则。对于许多不同的域实例，有许多证明。是的。请务必在你的播客应用程序或 adspthepodcast.com 查看这些节目说明
for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。我是反 Bryce。这一期还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。